اعتقل تجهيزه الامن في الشرطه في في رورو
رئيس الجمهوريه
بيدروكاستيا ووصفته في تغريده على تويتر
بالرئيس السابق للبلاد بينما اعلن
التلفزيون الرسميه ان رئيسه الوزراء بيتسي
شافيز اعلنت استقالتها وجاء ذلك بعد اعلان
كاستيا وحل البرلمان الذي تهيمين عليه
المعارضه اليمنيه التي صوتت لاحقا على
عزله بتهمه العجز الاخلاقي وتجاهلت
قراراته بحل البرلمان فرض حضره التجوال في
البلاد وقد سرع انصار الرئيس اليسرى كاسيو
بالتظاهر امام البرلمان بعد التصويت على
اصله
[تصفيق]
انا
الجزيره حسان مسعود حسان كيف وصلنا الى
هذه النقطه التي يعزل فيها رئيس الجمهوريه
بل يتحدث عن القاء القبض عليه
الصور التي تظهر الرئيس البيروفي بيدرو
كاستيلو وهو محتجز في مقر البلديه في
العاصمه ليما وذلك بعد اعتقاله من قبل
الشرطه عقب اعلانه لحاله الطوارئ وعزله
همم حله البرلمان البيروفيه وذلك في اطار
الازمه السياسيه الكبيره التي كانت تعيشها
البيرو منذ ما قبل وصول البدروكسي وفي
يوليو عام 2021 الى الحكم واستمرت هذه
الازمه حتى هذه اللحظه التي وصلنا اليها
اليوم
بعزل الرئيس من قبل البرلمان
البيروفي هذا البرلمان ذاته الذي كان
الرئيس بيدرو كاسيو قد قام بحله ظهر هذا
اليوم قام بعزله باغلبيه وصوت من اصل 130
صوتا واتى هذا العزل بعد ايضا رفض
القرارات من قبل همم مختلف المسؤولين في
البلاد هذه القرارات التي كان قد اطلقها
الرئيس البيروفي المعزول الان والمحتجز من
قبل الشرطه البيروفيه التي كانت تشمل حل
البرلمان فرض حاله الطوارئ وفرض حظر
للتجول بالاضافه الى اعلان حكومه طارئه
واستثنائيه ايضا اتى هذا العزل في اطار
ايضا همم عدم قبول نائبه الرئيس ايضا بهذا
القرار وهمم هذه النائبه نائبه الرئيس همم
من المفترض ان يتم اعلانها ايضا رئيسا
للبلاد تكون اول رئيسه امراه ل- البيرو
همم في تاريخ الديمقراطيه همم البيروفيه
وهي متجهه نحو البرلمان همم تقوم باداء
القسم واا ممارسه مهامها كرئي انتقاليه
بعد عزل الرئيس كاستيو طبعا هذا العزل اتى
بناء على توهم همم بعدم الاهليه الاخلاقيه
وفق ما وصفتها همم بدايه همم
المعارضه في البرلمان ثم الان ثم المقصود
قبل النيابه العامه بالقيام
ما المقصود بذلك
هذه هذه التهمه طبعا هي تشير لي الفساد
بشكل عام عاده ولكنه همم عندما لا يكون
هناك معلومات تدين الرئيس بشكل واضح تكون
هذه التهمه الفضفضه الى حد ما الى ان يتم
اثبات هذه التهم على الرئيس اذا الاهليه
الاخلاقيه مرتبطه بالفساد وكان همم كانت
النيابه العامه قد وجهت همم صباح هذا
اليوم توهما بالفساد للرئيس همم
البيروفي بادرو كاسيو على هذا الاساس كان
سيتم محاكمه الرئيس ومعرفه ما اذا كان همم
بالفعل هو متهم بهذه ياتها او ممارس لاي
من ممارسات الفساد ام لا
استنى مسعود بنسوي باولو شكرا جزيلا لك
وهذه هي الاخبار عن ااا القاء اجهزه
الشرطه البيروفيه القبضه على الرئيس
بيدروش شكرا»